l'italie est en proie aux guerres entre
la transe lempire d'autriche et les
aragon des deux siciles en france le roi
charles vii
épaulé par jeanne d'arc
pas définitivement les anglais et met
fin à la guerre de cent ans
dans les balkans le peuple des turcs
embrasse la religion musulmane écrase
l'empiré byzantin et annexes la bulgarie
et la roumanie
en espagne par contre les musulmans sont
définitivement chasser le pays s'unifie
les grandes navigations espagnol de
découverte commence et christophe colomb
découvre l'amérique
l'espagne et le portugal se partage des
territoires du nouveau monde à conquérir
et l'explorateur portugais majel lan
effectue le premier voyage maritime
autour du monde démontrant que la terre
est ronde
les nouvelles cartes donne alors un
aperçu plus précis du continent européen
et de ces nations
le mot europe devient d' usage commun et
une première conscience de l'identité
européenne se forme
c'est le début de l'époque moderne avec
la renaissance et l'humanisme qui
apporte la notion du libre arbitre et
prétendre à la divulgation du savoir
détenu depuis toujours par le clergé
martin luther dénoncent les privilèges
des papes et lance la réforme
protestante
mais il est aussitôt excommunié est mise
au ban par charles quint d'apps bourg
grands défenseurs de l'église catholique
charles quint héritier de l'empiré
d'autriche et d'espagne offre l'île de
malte à l'ordre militaire de saint jean
de jérusalem comme avant postes de la
chrétienté face aux turcs qui se
regroupent en avec d'autres nations
musulmanes ont formé l'empiré ottoman
quand les hautement envahissent la
hongrie charles quint l'eba partageant
la hongrie avec lui
l'angleterre hrs de l'irlande en suède
le roi du star premier se révoltent
contre la domination danoise et obtient
l'indépendance mais il doit défendre la
finlande contre les russes du tsar de
moscou ivan le terrible qui avaient
colonisé les terres jadis occupées par
les mongols
l'union de pologne lituanie hérite de la
tchéquie
en angleterre le roi henry viii tu
s'autoproclame chef suprême de l'église
anglicane se détachant de l'église de
rome dans l' empire d'autriche charles
quint à l'apogée de sa puissance
l empereur des territoires sur lesquels
le soleil ne se couche jamais pourtant
il abdique et son énorme empire est
divisé en deux son frère ferdinand
premier reçoit la couronne impériale en
autriche et son fils philippe 2 reçoit
l'espagne et les pays bas
ferdinand premier annexes aussitôt la
bohème et philippe 2 s'empare du
portugal et de ses colonies puis fâché
de savoir sa flotte de commerce ravagé
par des pirates ce anglais il envoie son
invincible armada envahir l'angleterre
mais il est subi
une désastreuse défaite cela permet aux
pays bas de guillaume d'orange de se
révolter contre le régime espagnol est
de créer la république des
provinces-unies devenant une nouvelle
puissance maritime et colonisant
l'afrique l'asie et l'amérique où la
nouvelle amsterdam
l'actuel new york est fondée
l'union de pologne lituanie s'étend
encore dominants de la mer baltique à la
mer noire
la suède aussi est à son apogée
son roi charles neuf fortement armés à
l'armée danoise s'approprie le nord de
la norvège
annexe l'estonie et attaque l'union de
paul sommes vite vanille lui prenant la
lettonie la pologne lituanie
affaibli par les attaques des ottomans
perd même la puce qui avait constitué
une puissante armée
dans l' empire d'autriche déchirée par
les conflits entre les protestants et
les catholiques les traités de west
valley mettre fin à la guerre de trente
ans et c'est alors que naît l'idée d'un
état moderne qui ne soit plus influencé
par l'église de rome
non
l'union de pologne lituanie perd encore
des territoires des bande de tarés de
slave nommé kozak s'installe au nord de
la mer noire et forme l'état de
l'ukraine
à cette époque la france de louis xiv et
de son ministre le cardinal mazarin est
la première puissance militaire et
culturelle d'europe le portugal reprend
son indépendance vis-à-vis de l'espagne
l'angleterre s'unit à l'ecosse sous le
règne dan stewart et se renomme le
royaume uni doté d'une puissante marine
qui domine les maires
toutefois une révolution pacifique
la glorieuse révolution anglaise
renverse seul espoir
le parlement du royaume uni institut
alors la monarchie constitutionnelle un
régime
qui met fin au pouvoir des souverains
les reléguant au sol cérémonie
officielle avec un premier ministre qui
gouverne le pays
c'est le siècle des lumières
isaac newton voltaire et d'autres zones
de culture diffuse le principe que
l'individu peut décider par son
raisonnement propres se libérant des
coutumes de la tradition
en france le pouvoir du roi reste entier
la lorraine et la corse sont
pacifiquement intégrer
à l'est de l'europe la russie commence
son expansion territoriale elle
assujettis des cosaques prend l'estonie
et la lettonie à la suède et démantèle
l'union pro l'homme dit mme annie la
partageant avec l' empire d'autriche et
la prusse
l' empire d'autriche annexe le
luxembourg les pays-bas et chasse les
ottomans de la croatie et de la hongrie
tandis que la puce du roi frédéric deux
despotes éclairés élargi ses territoires
et prend berlin pour capitale
mais voilà qu'en france éclater la
révolution
les droits de l'homme sont déclarés
les privilèges des nobles et du clergé
sont supprimés le roi la reine et des
milliers de noble français sont
guillotinés
cela provoque l'indignation de la
noblesse européenne est une coalition de
royaumes déclare la guerre à la france
c'est le début de l'époque contemporaine
mais à paris c'est le chaos
la politique de la terreur provoque des
vengeances les révolutionnaires se tuent
entre eux et robespierre l'un des
protagonistes de la révolution est
lui-même guillotiné dans ce désordre
politique le général napoléon bonaparte
prend les pleins pouvoirs il contre
attaque
par la coalition anti françaises et
occupe lempire d'autriche
de retour en france est acclamée par la
foule
napoléon se couronne alors empereur des
français
napoléon poursuit ses conquêtes et pas
la plus permettant à la pologne de se
recréer la principauté du liechtenstein
prend son indépendance par rapport à l'
empire d'autriche napoléon annexes eux
mêmes les pays-bas la suisse l'italie et
l'espagne
mais quand il attaque la russie celle ci
qui avait enlevé la finlande à la suède
et une partie de la roumanie à l' empire
ottoman brûle ses propres terres et
rejoint la coalition anti françaises
sans ressources alimentaires les troupes
françaises se retire de la russie et
pour napoléon c'est la défaite car il
est définitivement vaincu à waterloo
l' empire français aboli la france
restaure sa monarchie et au congrès de
vienne les nations occupé récupèrent
leurs anciens territoires
les pays bas la belgique et le
luxembourg se déclare indépendant
tout comme la grèce qui se libèrent des
ottomans et instaure la monarchie
la suède s'approprie la norvège tandis
que la france et la russie se re partage
la pologne la rayant à nouveau de la
carte
à cette époque
la prusse et le plus riche et le plus
puissant des états germaniques sont rois
guillaume premier par les troupes
autrichiennes et se couronne empereur
d'allemagne
l'autriche vers la couronne impériale
mais en héritant de la couronne
hongroise elle devient le royaume
d'autriche hongrie
entre temps le roi piémontais
victor-emmanuel deux avaient envahi les
états italien et formés le royaume
d'italie y incorporant même les états
pontificaux
la france devenue second empire
déclarent la guerre à l'allemagne
mais vas tu elle lui c'est l'alsace et
la lorraine et retrouve son statut de
république
à l'est de l'europe lempire hautement
père dépossession chip est prise par le
royaume uni tandis que la roumanie la
serbie et la bulgarie proclament leur
indépendance vis-à-vis des ottomans
le portugal chasse le roi et passe au
statut de république
l'albanie se libère elle aussi de l'
empire ottoman et devient une république
tandis que la norvège prend son
indépendance vis-à-vis de la suède et
restaure la monarchie